[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es ein richtig schnelles
rezept ich werde nämlich zwiebelblumen
machen das klingt jetzt am anfang
vielleicht ein bisschen komisch und
nicht so ganz appetitlich
aber das sind wirklich die besten
zwiebel die ich je gegessen habe
die zwiebelringe kennt ihr vielleicht
die frittierten diese zwiebelblumen sind
nicht nur lecker sondern sehen auch
richtig hübsch aus und ihr könnt sie vor
allem zum grillen dazu servieren ihr
könnt sie als vorspeise servieren oder
auch als richtig schöne und leckere
beilagen
vielleicht habt ihr auch schon mal im
internet gesehen und ich zeige euch
heute wie man sie ganz einfach selber
machen kann
hier vorne stehen schon mal die zutaten
ich nehme dafür zwei gemüsezwiebeln die
sind auch richtig groß also nehmt
einfach ganz großer gemüsezwiebel zwei
eier habe ich ein viertel teelöffel
pfeffer einen viertel teelöffel salz
nachhall mithilfe paprikapulver und ganz
viel nähe
ich nehme jetzt öfter mal die zwiebeln
und die werden jetzt geschält und da
müsste jetzt darauf aufpassen dass die
wurzel hier unten dran bleibt das heißt
hier oben ein paar weg
schneide ich hier die wurzel ganz
vorsichtig ab aber so dass eben noch der
ansatz hier stehen bleibt damit die
zwiebel eben nicht auseinanderfällt
[Musik]
die zwiebel sondern einen das so
aussehen also richtig schön blumen für
mich und ich zeige euch jetzt einen
trick wie das am einfachsten
funktioniert
dafür nehmen die zwiebel und ein großes
messer und ich habe jetzt hier diese
besser mit 10 mm ihr könnt aber auch
wenn jetzt keine zeit gehabt einfach
zwei gegenstände nehmen die gleich hoch
sind also etwa 1 cm
das kann zum beispiel ein kochlöffel
sein oder auch einfach ein anderer
gegenstand oder ihr macht komplett ohne
und muss einfach aufpassen jetzt
schneidet ihr die zwiebel erst einmal
greifen kreuzförmig ein und die tölzer
helfen einfach dabei dass er nicht
komplett runter schneidet so jetzt habe
ich sie schon mal hier im viertel
geschnitten und jetzt werden 16 teile
daraus das heißt ich muss das ganze noch
mal zweimal vierteln
[Musik]
dann nehme ich jetzt die 2 und da kommen
jetzt die gewürze mit rein
und hier können wir auch gerne gewürze
nach wahl nehmen gerne rosen schaf oder
auch edelsüß nehmen beim paprikapulver
das entscheide wie einfach selbst
[Musik]
und jetzt kommt etwas aufwändigere
partie jetzt öffnet ihr ganz vorsichtig
die zwiebeln und jetzt wird die zwiebel
erst einmal gewählt das heißt einmal
komplett außen und innen und damit es
ein bisschen einfacher geht könnt ihr
auch einen löffel nehmen und wirklich
zwischen jede zwiebel schicht mehr
eingeben
das sorgt dann später dafür dass die
zwiebel sich schon öffnet beim
frittieren und vor allem dass die schön
knusprig wird
[Musik]
als nächstes nehme ich jetzt die
einmischung und wer die zwiebelblumen
damit bestreichen
[Musik]
jetzt dürfte die zwiebel lange genug
warten und jetzt kommst du wieder in die
mail mischung und dann wirst du noch mal
komplett paniert
[Musik]
so sehen die zwiebeln jetzt aus ich
hatte noch ein bisschen eifrig deswegen
habe ich sogar noch eine dritte zwiebel
paniert und ich habe ich jetzt bereits
frittierfett und zwar in einem großen
topf ich habe jetzt keinen mittleren
topf das heißt und mittlere topf ein
bisschen besser da hätte ich jetzt keine
drei liter frittierfett sondern nur zwei
liter gebraucht aber das ist völlig okay
und das werde jetzt erwärmt auf etwa 180
grad auf mittel hoher hitze und in der
zwischenzeit kann ich schon mal die soße
machen und zwar mache ich muss sagen ich
zeige euch mal die zutaten für die
saatkrähen brauche ich 200 gramm saure
sahne 100 gramm naturjoghurt ich habe
ich eine fein gerieben der knoblauchzehe
und viertel teelöffel salz und pfeffer
und zwei esslöffel olivenöl
die zutaten werden jetzt einfach ganz
kurz berühren
beim joghurt könnt ihr jetzt entweder
einen zehnprozentigen ebenso wie ich
immer gerne nehmen oder einen 35
prozentigen sowie jetzt einfach ein
bisschen cremiger
[Musik]
da jetzt noch salz pfeffer und die
knoblauchzehe und wenn ihr möchtet könnt
ihr die sour cream zum beispiel auch mit
einem esslöffel essig abschmecken
aber das brauche ich jetzt hier nicht
weil der basilika date immer so leicht
säuerlich also das nicht mit süß und
dann eher leicht säuerlich und es passt
wirklich hier hervorragend diese creme
ist bereit
und jetzt muss ich nur noch aufs
frittierfett warten das feld hat jetzt
die richtige temperatur ist darf
natürlich nicht zu heiß sein und ich
nehme immer ganz gerne zur probe ein
joystick spießchen schaschlikspieß und
halte den hinein und wenn der kleine
blume blasen am rand zu sehen sind dann
ist es wirklich perfekt jetzt müsst ihr
ganz vorsichtig arbeiten sowie allgemein
beim frittieren und jetzt lege ich so
eine zwiebel blume auf mein schöpflöffel
bzw
dass ich jetzt an pfannenwender jetzt
kommt dass hier ein ganz vorsichtig
und dann wird sie für ihr auf vier bis
sieben minuten von der einen seite
gebraten und dann für etwa zwei bis vier
minuten unter anderem also am ende soll
sie einfach schön goldbraun sein
[Musik]
die zwiebelblumen in der friteuse dass
es die eine variante aber ich habe auch
noch eine variante im backofen dafür
nämlich jetzt ein backblech legt eine
dauer back folie drauf und die zwiebel
jetzt könnt ihr die mit etwas fett
bestreichen also mit olivenöl oder
sonnenblumenöl oder ihr nehmt ganz
einfach bakterium spray da ist er
wirklich nur rein pflanzliches fett mit
dabei und dann könnt ihr die blume jetzt
so damit besprühen so dass einfach
überall fest dran ist und jetzt kommt
den vorgeheizten backofen bei etwa 210
grad ober unterhitze solange er ein
bisschen schön goldbraun ist die
variante ist vorzubereiten herrn
bisschen sicherer weil man nicht frieren
muss aber natürlich ist es ein bisschen
trockener als die frittierte blume jetzt
fragt ihr euch wahrscheinlich mensch was
mache ich denn mit dem übrigen
frittierfett also wenn die frittierfett
habe und es wieder verwenden möchte dann
kann ich durch ein sieb geben damit
einfach die rückstände weg gehen und ich
es wieder verwenden kann
ich hatte das ist aber schon zum zweiten
mal verwendet und außerdem war zwiebeln
das heißt dass richtet auch sehr stark
nach zwiebeln
jetzt werde ich entsorgen und macht das
jetzt einfach so ich geh jetzt wieder
zurück in die ursprungs flasche deswegen
habe ich die auch immer ganz gerne auf
und dann könnt ihr es einfach abgekühlt
eben in die mülltonne schmeißen
wichtig ist dass vor dem abfüllen in die
flasche das frittierfett wirklich
komplett erkaltet ist und dann könnte es
rein für und dann ganz ganz einfach im
restmüll wegschmeißen
[Musik]
die zwiebelblumen habe ich nach dem
frittieren einfach auch etwas
küchenpapier gelegt damit das fett
abtropfen kann so sieht sie jetzt aus
bei mir sitzt ein bisschen abgekühlt
denn wir haben zwischendurch noch fotos
gemacht aber am ende ist es aber so dass
jeder ein stück zwiebel nimmt und dann
kann man sich das hochrhein drucken und
einfach probieren so schön und so sieht
jetzt die variante aus dem backofen aus
da habe ich den backofen allerdings
umgestellt auf heißluft und dann auf
unter hitze denn die spitzen wurden ein
bisschen dunkel und dann habe ich das
ganze so etwa für 25 bis 30 minuten
gebacken und die probiere ich jetzt auch
mal also die äußeren sind bestimmten
mega knusprig so sehen sie aus
und die sind ein bisschen weiche aber
das finde ich gar nicht so schlecht als
aus der fritteuse werden sie natürlich
sehr knusprig was man beachten sollte
aber die war doch was man beachten
sollte dass man die zwiebel dann gleich
serviert das heißt wenn ihr die
vorbereiten wollt könnt ihr wirklich
schon die zwiebel panieren mit mehl und
dann einfach nur auf der küchentheke
stehen lassen und kurz vor dem servieren
dann frittieren oder in den backofen
schieben und dann wirklich ganz heiß
servieren
so schmeckt sie am besten und ich hoffe
dass ich euch auch jetzt lust drauf
gemacht habe auf diese richtig schöne
und vor allem leckere zwiebelblumen und
wenn ja dann schaut das rezept noch mal
an aufs feld der ehe und wir sehen uns
einen ganzen nächsten mal wieder biss
dann tue ich hab heute nutzen weil ich
habe auch zwiebel unter der zunge
jetzt ist er weg
[Musik]
also wieder andreas